what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i am going
to be reacting
to a video that was sent to me by one of
my subscribers on instagram
labeled toxic masculinity listen to
black
woman um as you guys know um i'm trying
to hit 20 000 subscribers this month so
if you have a chance hit that subscribe
button
and ring the notification bell alright
let's see what it says
welcome to a special episode of listen
to black women
the show that tells you what black women
are thinking and while we're right
this season has been filled with some
pretty awesome topics okay so genuine
question
like if i had a show that claimed
to speak on behalf of all of white women
i don't think that would be accurate i
don't know how you could claim to speak
on all of black women
because like there's so many different
black women out there like they don't
think the same sunlight that's what
bothers me about shows like this
and others kind of heavy one of our
deeper subjects that's been a hot topic
is toxic masculinity and this season
we went there in our episode are we
experiencing a crisis of toxic
masculinity
we didn't just define what it is our
host spoke on the impact it's having on
black women
and culture this statistic kind of hurt
me the most with
do men in today's society protect women
with 77 percent
of us saying no and even though okay
so they're actually using stats i like
that better
so maybe they are who knows huh
i feel that way do you guys think that
correlates with the stat that like one
in four black women
are unmarried so probably the 75 percent
that don't
think it think that men protect women
are the ones that aren't married so
my girls feel that way it still is it's
hard to hear
that we're out here feeling really alone
and that we have to do this thing
by ourselves and there is no covering of
protection like we were raised to think
we were going to get
sadly this feeling of being unprotected
isn't just a notion
it became a viral conversation in 2018
after a young black woman was attacked
by a white man
in a mcdonald's in florida while her
male co-workers simply watched
our hope is that speaking on it will
promote awareness and change
now here's the thing about toxic
masculinity it takes many okay
this is the thing i hate about
influencers
guys we're not doing [ __ ] like i can
spread awareness
to this video right or a different video
but the
the rapists and the murderers aren't out
there
aren't gonna see this and think hmm
hmm i'm gonna just stop murdering and
raping today no
guys they don't care what we think and
the the real people that promote change
and the real people that should be
patted on the back are the people like
the fbi agents the cops the people that
are actually like protecting people
not not the social media influencers who
share a link like you're not doing
anything
reforms abandonment is one police and
women is another
check out this clip from an episode of
listen to black women
earlier this year sierra had the
internet mad because she posted a video
from a sermon from john gray
too many women want to be married but
you're walking in the spirit of
girlfriend
ask the lord to deliver you from that
spirit and carry yourself like you're
already taken
and i promise you when you carry
yourself like a wife a husband will find
you
and sierra now that she's a wife had
decided that her best response to that
was
level up so as y'all can imagine the
internet was in an
uproar over that mess because they were
like level up like girl weren't you just
a baby mama a couple years ago as you
can see
men aren't the only culprits when it
comes to policing women and our hosts
aren't afraid to speak on all
offenders especially those on repeat
like okay what is policing women
i i don't understand like is policing
women saying where i disagree with
certain women
is policing women where i call out bad
women's behavior like what
i need you to define police who made
headlines again
at the end of 2018 for making a
controversial statement
many believed celebrated treating black
women like mules
check out this clip from listen to black
women there
are just so many industries now that are
built on
preying on the like insecurities and
desperation of black
women and specifically i feel like the
church is one of the biggest culprits he
was on a show to promote
a book yes and once again here is
another man telling a woman what we need
to do to be chosen to be valued
and it just continues to promote just
this like story of hey i don't
see a wedding ring on her finger don't
see one
i don't think any of these girls are
married um
i what
i mean the question is do you want to be
married if you don't want to be married
then why do you care what men are saying
what they want to marry
if you want to be married then it's like
i worked in sales before
and you want to talk to the buyer about
what they want in order to find the
right product
and i'm not i'm not saying that women
are like the equivalent of a product but
like
at the end of the day you're selling
yourself how we have to mule
to be worthy it's too much and there's
no balance should women birth men
absolutely not first man sadly toxic
masculinity is so pervasive
it's challenging for women to set
boundaries with men we're not even in
relationships with
you know where we're going okay i
actually agree
that women in general are pretty we're
more agreeable and i think a lot of
times women do
do things for men that they don't
actually like want to do
i'm not even talking like sexually i'm
just talking like in terms
of
i don't even know like in terms of doing
things for their boyfriend or spending
all their time with their boyfriend
or um even like just not being able to
say no like i just think girls have a
hard time saying no because like
naturally we're people pleasers
so i do like think that women
could bene i actually think every girl
could benefit from like
assertiveness training r kelly
despite accusations of toxic behavior
against women ranging from pedophilia to
deviant cult like actions
people and most notably black women
can't seem to cancel the infamous singer
on this episode of listen to black women
we broke down why
music is a form of hypnosis like even if
you take it all the way to life
not to get too wild biblical but
obviously when you think about lucifer
for anyone who doesn't know
like this was the illest musician on all
the blocks
in heaven she did okay because he wasn't
okay what do you guys mean by cancel him
because i'm sorry some of his songs slap
he should go to jail i'm not gonna deny
that
but like some of his songs slap you
can't can't deny that
exactly so that's why he
allegedly likes to roam free through the
entertainment industry
unfortunately what tracy just said is
the only thing about the entire r kelly
fiasco that makes sense and of course
it came from a black woman thanks to all
of the madden noir and hello beautiful
fans for watching us this season
share your thoughts on toxic message
okay question do they
mean that even like candace owens is
gonna represent them and
like women that have very clearly
very clearly different ideologies like
obviously
um yeah i don't know this kind of just
seemed like a lot of nonsense to me i
didn't
even understand what their point was
or like what exact change they're trying
to make
let me know in the comments if you did
you think i'm off i don't know
don't forget subscribe to the channel
bring that notification bell we're
trying to get to 20 000 subscribers
i love you all i will talk to you guys
later